bien merci la parole à Monsieur
Christian Cambon pour le groupe UMP
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre un peu plus d'un an c'est
écoulé depuis le dramatique attentat de
Toulouse ça a été évoqué ici toute cet
après-midi et l'affaire Mera n'en finit
pas d'alimenter les controverses et le
débat sur les supposés au réels
imperfection de notre système intérieur
de protection mais dans le même temps en
l'espace d'un an le contexte a
considérablement changé et il s'estélas
dégradé la situation au Sahel et plus
particulièrement au Mali a contraint la
France à intervenir militairement dans
les conditions que l'on sait ce faisant
notre pays s'est aussi exposé à des
risques de représaill particulièrement
élevés de fait les appels de chef
djihadistes à frappé les intérêts
français partout dans le monde commence
à être suivi des faits j'en veux pour
preuve l'attentat contre notre ambassade
à Tripoli et la tentative d'attentat
contre notre ambassade au Ker tout ceci
sont des signes des des signes d'alertes
des signes de danger sur les risques que
la France encours de voir son propre
territoire touché par ces attentats
autour de nous les exemples font frémir
après l'Algérie à inaménace les
États-Unis à Boston la Turquie
dernièrement tout ceci montre que des
états particulièrement bien armés pour
lutter contre le terrorisme aveugle
peuvent être eux aussi touchés en leur
cœur un un djihadiste français cela a
été évoqué a été interpellé il a appelé
à importer sur notre territoire la
guerre sainte et ça nous appelle ça nous
rappelle une réalité nouvelle de jeunes
Français vont s'entraîner dans des camps
en Afghanistan au Pakistan Ils vont
recevoir des formations au djihad dans
ces pays où les groupes terroristes sont
implantés et ils peuvent comme ma comme
ça s'est passé à Boston à Londres à
Madrid dans des attentats précédents
trouver sur le territoire national des
complecités mais aussi des
approvisionnements en armes et en
explosif alors face à ces dangers les
nos concitoyens sont réellement inquiets
aussi monsieur le ministre je voudrais
simplement savoir si le niveau de
coopération européenne est suffisant
pour nous aider à traquer l'ensemble de
ces individus car la réponse ne peut pas
être nationale la France est
particulièrement exposée l'Europe doit
nous aider quelle est l'action que vous
menez dans ce sens merci Monsieur Manuel
Vals monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur Christian Cambon là aussi en
écho à des propos très justes peut-être
quelques
depuis 2001 au total plus de 200
volontaires ont quitté la France pour
s'engager dans une filière jihadiste 17
sont morts dans les zones de combat et
69 de ces personnes séjournent
actuellement sur notre territoire le
développement des départs de volontaires
vers la Syrie constitue en revanche à
partir de 2012 une véritable rupture
plus d'une centaine de personnes se sont
rendu sur ce territoire sur ce théâtre
de guerre en seulement un an et demi ce
contingent atteint en effet 60 % du
total des volontaires et on constate y
compris le départ d'individus mineurs
sans expérience religieuse qui s'engage
sur un coup de tête ce phénomène touche
d'autres pays c'est vrai au Maghreb mais
c'est vrai en Europe ce qui nous amène à
renforcer je pense à nos amis belges
notre coopération l'échange
d'information évidemment un travail
commun mais il y a là un véritable
danger pour nous et pour nos intérêts et
nous faisons face évidemment par
l'engagement des de nos services de
renseignement et je vous donne un autre
chiffre 78 personnes ont été
interpellées par la dcéie dans le cadre
de la lutte antiterroriste en 2012
contre 47 en 2011 et depuis le début de
l'année ce chiffre s'élève déjà à 38
interpellations qui ont donné lieu à 12
écrous cela veut bien dire et cela fait
écho aussi au propos du sénateur Alain
Richard que il y a une menace et qu'elle
est concrète elle ne relève pas
uniquement du fantasme ou de la
recherche de stigmatisation elle repose
sur des faits réels la situation très
dégradée au Sahel en Libye en Tunisie
bien évidemment en Syrie et sur des
filières que nous devons combattre à
travers la coopération internationale et
le travail de nos services de
renseignement merci mon cher collègue
Monsieur Christian Cambon oui je
voudrais remercier le le le ministre à
la fois des données statistiques qu'il
vient de nous fournir et de la prise en
compte de ce risque qui est bien qui est
bien réelrais juste revenir sur un point
la nécessité qu'il y a encore que
l'ensemble des pays européens se trouve
véritablement mobilisé peut-être une
conférence des ministres européens sur
ce thème serait le bienvenu car le
danger peut se produire et pas et faire
éruption par de très nombreuses
frontières qui sont encore trop lâches
en Europe merci Monsieur le Ministre
merci